that's a that's a great question you
know prior to coming to this state
department I spent the last 10 years of
my life working to bridge the digital
divide you know I like everybody else in
the mid and late 90s was witnessing this
technology driven change in the way that
we communicated in transacted business
and and a handful of friends of mine and
I in 2000 started a nonprofit called one
economy the purpose of which was to
connect people around the globe to these
technologies and and we went from hip
floor guys in a basement actually being
the world's largest digital divide
organization and one of the things that
I've seen over the last ten years and
again this is working in the nonprofit
sector this is not working in government
is there is a very very fast adoption of
these technologies around the globe is
it everywhere no but it's increasingly
universal one of the things that one of
the what are the one of the important
points that people need to bear in mind
is that the way that people actually
access the network in the developing
world might be different than the way
people in the United States are
accessing the network of the six built
there are six billion people on the
planet but there are also four billion
mobile phones so we can already see
right now in the developing world people
are skipping sort of the desktop as the
way in which they access the network and
they're accessing it directly on their
handhelds one of the places where I'm
doing a lot of work right now is in the
Democratic Republic of Congo which is
one of the the poorest places on earth
and and one of the things that that the
State Department is hoping to do there
is use telecommunications and use
technology tools as a way of protecting
women particularly in eastern Congo who
are vulnerable to acts of extreme
violence
of rape and in examining the feasibility
of this you know I said oh you know it
sounds great but you know is that naive
you know number one is there can people
use cell phones are they using them what
about literacy gaps and one of the
things that I learned was that today at
this moment fifty percent of the country
and it is a massive country with a land
mass equal to Texas in Alaska combined
fifty percent of the country right now
is covered by a wireless signal and 14
out of every 100 people in the Congo are
already mobile phone subscribers and one
of the things that's different in the
Congo that's different in the United
States is in the United States everybody
has their own phone but in the Congo its
normal actually for three or four people
to share the same phone and so if you
just do the math all right today 14 out
of every 100 people or mobile phone
subscribers if you assume that there are
three users per phone what that means is
that today without the United States
doing a thing forty-two percent of the
country are already on mobile phones so
in one of the poorest regions of the
earth the Congo we already see that half
of the people are connecting to the
network and so that for me is is great
affirmation that we should be pushing
these technologies into the developing
world and further we should be thinking
about how 21st century technology can
help solve some of our most intractable
development challenges and will there be
places where we go where people simply
aren't using cell phones where there's
no mobile coverage where the literacy
level is such that people just can't
figure it out sure but I think that
instead of just waiting for the world to
catch up the United States can play a
role in helping to lead and so in
looking at the Congo again um fifty
percent of the country is covered today
but a study that I saw by Goldman Sachs
said that by 2013 eighty-eight percent
of the country will be covered so part
of it makes sense to me for us to engage
now while sort of the whole world is
getting on to these technologies and
figuring out now how we can use these
technologies for economic and social
good
I think that there is a lot of
unintended paternalism when people think
about technology we oftentimes assume
that people who are low-income or people
who are racial minorities are somehow
not going to understand technology and
that we need to sort of parse out giving
access to technology to people who are
low-income people who are who are racial
minorities and I think that I think that
that that that is just completely
contradictory to what actually all the
data and evidence show which is that it
doesn't matter how much money is in your
wallet it doesn't matter from whence you
come young people all around the globe
right now have this incredibly intuitive
understanding of Technology and of its
power and so introducing technology into
poor communities doesn't need to be done
so paternalistic Lee because guess what
within a couple days this 15 year olds
going to be way ahead of you and so
that's one thing that I that that is
very important to me is to take some of
the paternalism that I think lives in a
lot of our development practices and
recognize that when it comes to
introducing technology when it comes to
develop into introducing innovation into
poor communities don't be too arrogant
about it because the folks they are
going to be a lot quicker with it a lot
smarter about it than you in very short
order
I think that I think there are a number
of examples one of the problems
particularly in the developing world is
the lack of medical workers arm so you
know you go into places of extreme
poverty with enormous prevalence of of
disease and he you've got one or two
health care workers literally trying to
steward the medical interests of
thousands of patients in need so one way
in which technology can play a good role
beyond just giving alerts you know it's
twelve o'clock it's time to take the
green pill another way is to actually
push in preventative in for preventative
information to people so one of the
examples that I've seen it's very very
compelling is for pregnant women and
pushing content to them by SM by SMS
about what are those things that can be
done to ensure the health of fetus to
ensure a healthy pregnancy the thing
that I think is more exciting though
I've talked about push technology what I
think is more interesting and compelling
than that even is being able to create
some exchange so right now if there is a
sorghum farmer in Mali and that sorghum
farmer has lost fifty percent of his
crop and he doesn't know why right now
the way in which we would provide aid to
that farmer is some professor in Surrey
goes to goes to the airport in London
flies to Lagos flies to Molly gets in a
Jeep drives for three hours looks at the
crop and says oh this is what you've got
today there's no reason why that farmer
shouldn't be able to take a video
enabled phone or a photo enabled phone
take a dozen pictures of the crop um
send those you know send those over
mobile network send those over by email
to the professor in Surrey and rather
than the three airplane fight of flights
in the three
our Jeep ride in the five thousand
dollars in expenses that person can say
oh this is the problem this is what you
do oh and by the way in the meantime
you've saved two weeks and you know
another third of the the farmers crop so
a lot of what I'm interested in doing is
figuring out how experts can connect to
the agricultural world can connect to
entrepreneurs and provide real time
technical assistance that's exchange
rather than just pushing things and
rather than people having to physically
be there but create some virtual
connections between people
absolutely look it would be completely
naive of me to say oh here's the
internet here's 21st century
technologies kumbaya democracy wins
that's that's not realistic that's not
the world that we're living in I do
believe that access to technology
provides people with information that
they otherwise wouldn't be getting I
think that that expands their worldview
I think the young people growing up in
Gaza today who are being who can access
the internet and can get information
other than what they might be hearing
from the mala do I think that that is
like that that is in America's foreign
policy interests absolutely all of that
said America's enemies al Qaeda those
those entities that want to destroy us
are sophisticated in their own use of
technology and we're and and they know
how to use it for communication they
know how to use it for recruitment I
mean you can go on the internet right
now and in Google a handful of terms and
you can it terms you can see these these
recruitment websites we've seen them do
horrible things on the Internet um you
know where they will where they will
exploit on people who they've captured
in who their who they're they're
torturing or killing so this technology
offers a universe of resources to
everybody and that doesn't just
necessarily mean the good guys and that
we all live happily ever after do I
think that this is a powerful tool for
social good for economic good and for
democracy absolutely but it would be
naive of me and naive of anybody to
simply say oh well you know we can use
this they want this is they you know we
will win the the war for people's minds
and hearts you know without any push
back up by by virtue of the power of
these networks